alors si sur le tour de france le
maillot a une importance capitale sur
certaines plages c'est exactement le
contraire un million et demi de
personnes n'auront pas de marques
disgracieuses sur les fesses cet été en
france et pour cause des maillots elle
n'en met pas ce sont les naturistes qui
sont chaque année un peu plus nombreux à
goûter aux joies du grand air dans le
plus simple appareil
reportage en gironde dans un camp un peu
retranché qui accueille dix mille
naturiste perrine dutreil et verts et
l'udc vivre nu idée saugrenue pour les
un véritable mode de vie pour d'autres
depuis qu'elle a goûté au naturisme la
famille bourdon n'envisage plus de
passer ses vacances à billets édités
c'est toute une philosophie de vie
en vrac le respect de l'environnement de
son corps de celui des autres et l'on
vit des différences sociales difficiles
ici de distinguer un pdg d'un ouvrier
mais tous aux mêmes maux même diapason
on regarde pas la différence sur une
personne qui peut avoir un maillot de
grands couturiers ou un maillot acheté
dans une grande surface
on est tous pareils paradoxalement pour
vivre ont toute liberté leur naturisme
ses adeptes doivent passer leurs
vacances en fermer le centre de
montalivet donc organisé comme une
petite ville on y trouve tout
supermarché cinéma coiffeur mêmes
quincaillerie tout est là pour vivre en
autarcie si toutes nos courses ici et
quelquefois on va sur le marché monte à
corte très rarement on sort quasiment
jamais
et on se détend dans le plus simple
appareil le t-shirt n'étant souvent là
que pour protéger des coups de soleil
le tout dans un périmètre limité
filtrage à l'entrée hautes barrières
surveillance permanente
le dispositif de sécurité est imposante
dissuasif même pour les visiteurs non
inviter des personnes indésirables qui
viendrait à mourir pour des idées un peu
saugrenue on essaie d'éviter qu'elles
rendent donc ça nous permet de faire un
petit filtre sachant que c'est un grand
centre de 175 hectares donc c'est pas
évident le ser venus les ados font
exception à la règle pour être habillé
devient à ce moment là un atout de
séduction ne quitte pas le centre pour
autant le lendemain la tenue d'adam et
eve est à nouveau de rigueur on déjeune
en famille à l'abri des regards
indiscrets heureux parce que cacher